[Música]
ardor Frenesí ímpetu los 5 ganadores de
la segunda edición del concurso África
Fashion up se preparan para defender sus
colecciones vinieron de Costa de Marfil
Marruecos Congo brazaville Kenia
Sudáfrica Con qué propósito
para mostrar esta nueva juventud
africana que está compitiendo con los
diseñadores occidentales que quieren
sacudir los códigos que quieren cambiar
las cosas De hecho no hay falta de
creatividad
quiera que vaya a África puede ver que
mire donde Mire
[Música]
qué colores hay creatividad hay muchas
cosas inventándose todo el tiempo
pero en algún momento hay códigos para
poder vender internacionalmente hay una
forma de trabajar una forma de preparar
las colecciones por eso hemos encontrado
una colaboración con balenciaga que nos
apoya realmente desde la primera edición
los acompañan tienen una masterclass y
tienen un curso de tutoría de cuatro
meses con ellos y la mayoría de los
empresarios no tienen necesariamente los
conocimientos necesarios para crear una
empresa así con hec todo lo que es
negocio marketing comunicación con hs
podemos ayudarles a continuar su
formación para que puedan desarrollar su
marca así como su creatividad
toda competición necesita patrocinadores
mecenas y una madrina para existir hoy
la diseñadora de moda muy parisina
clarice
en la ciudad para mí es importante dar
ejemplo cuáles son los principales
obstáculos del continente africano en la
actualidad
creo que lo importante y No
necesariamente solo en el continente
africano es tener socios financieros
para poder financiar nuestras
colecciones
sobre todo si estamos en el sector de
lujo realmente necesitamos digamos
financiadores
conocimientos técnicos saber cómo
construir colecciones
estrategia marketing Es realmente un
conjunto
radicado en abellán Brain Fernández ha
desarrollado su Marca a partir de
tejidos estampados producidos en Mali y
Costa de Marfil pero eso fue antes de la
competencia Costa de Marfil para mí para
mí la moda africana Más allá de ser un
estampado un material es ante todo un
espíritu es una dedicatoria a todos los
pueblos del norte de África
y todo Así que para mí el blanco Es
realmente la esencia de La pureza y la
ligereza
la única mujer ganadora del concurso
África Fashion app es marroquí mina
vinebin solo tiene un sueño romper los
esquemas
qué le molesta de la moda marroquí
Marruecos Siempre es lo mismo es muy
limitado no está permitido llevar cosas
demasiado cortas cosas demasiado
escotadas Los hombres tienen que
vestirse de una manera las mujeres de
otra y yo digo no si quieres ponerte un
Corsa y eres un hombre póntelo si
quieres llevar algo corto Llévalo No
tengas miedo y por qué no
en Congo Brasil yangrich se dedicaba a
lermanga si no se pasaba las noches
entreteniéndose con sus computadores y
se nota en su estilo personal tengo un
estilo solo mi estilo personal de vestir
es extremadamente ecléctico
eso significa que una semana puedo pasar
de un uniforme militar
a un traje recolector de basura o a
cualquier cosa la moda para mí es muy
conlleva mucho humor
tiene que tener humor tiene que amar la
vida y la vida consiste en probar un
montón de pequeñas cosas diferentes
y mi estilo creo que en este momento es
ese son muy ecléctico con una buena
dosis de Japón
en cuanto a mullisime Edi Patrick no
pudo viajar a París debido a su visado
nacido en kigali Ruanda creció en
nairobi Kenia donde desarrolló su marca
su credo borrar las construcciones
sociales limitantes como el género
creando trajes andróginos el ganador
conjunto de la edición de 2022 comparte
su premio con el alocado sudafricano
jacks bam que inició sus primeras
colecciones de moda a los 9 años hoy en
día no duda en llevar el mismo su
concepto de la moda
cree en mi marca bancolective hace tres
años es una marca totalmente inspirada
en los sudafricanos Los percibo
tremendamente Alegres les gusta
divertirse pueden hacer bromas sobre
cualquier cosa tiene El corazón alegre y
es genial estar con ellos
pero como economía emergente nuestra
gente no se viste necesariamente de
forma que refleje nuestra personalidad
sudafricana
Así que creo una especie de utopía
sudafricana una forma de vestir Si
fuéramos de un país de primera clase
es muy colorido experimental atrevido
con muchos estampados es increíblemente
vibrante y alegre no es serio pero sí
con mucha clase eso es lo que hago con
mi marca
en la graduación lloraba de alegría ante
la idea de pasar unos meses entre hf y
balenciaga estudiando nuevas estrategias
de marketing Sí porque la africana o no
es un sueño y un negocio